lady gaga's meeting with the Dalai Lama  has landed her in hot water the 30 year  old pop star shared this shot on Sunday  shaking hands with the Dalai Lama at the  US Conference of Mayors the pair joined  a panel and discussed the benefits of  kindness and compassion you don't have  to look far for kindness but the meeting  sparked outrage in some Chinese fans  China's rulers consider the Dalai Lama a  separatist and have accused him of  leading a failed uprising against the  Chinese government Reuters reports that  a Chinese foreign ministry spokesman  addressed the aftermath of gagas meeting  in a briefing saying quote after the  relevant incident happened if you look  at comments on the Chinese internet  their anger has welled up